[Musique]
à partir du 1er décembre vous pourriez
être admissible à recevoir
1300 dollars par enfant pour couvrir les
sondes notre équipe s'est battue avec
acharnement pour les sondages et je veux
que tout le monde le sache
Justin Trudeau officiellement lancé
jeudi dans une clinique de London dans
l'Ontario la prestation dentaire
canadienne provisoires qui va financer
les soins des jeunes de moins de 12 ans
première étape un programme qui doit à
terme offrir une couverture complète à
tous les Canadiens moins entiers lancés
avec des élus des enfants et des
étudiants dentisterie mais sans le chef
du NPD même si Jack mythique avait fait
ce programme une condition pour appuyer
le gouvernement libéral minoritaire
entre libéraux et conservateur le chef
du NPD a-t-il de la difficulté à sortir
de l'ombre j'ai posé la question à Jack
meeting
bonjour merci d'être avec nous bonjour
oui c'est un plaisir je signe on a lancé
le gouvernement lancé cette semaine la
prestation dentaire canadienne c'était
l'une de vos demandes pour appuyer le
gouvernement Trudeau
le gouvernement Trudeau vous donne pas
beaucoup de crédit pour cette mesure là
ce que vous avez l'impression que vous
êtes vous êtes fait avoir un petit peu
non je sais je pense que tout le monde
ça tout le monde sait que c'était nous
qui ont proposé cette idée on a fait la
campagne pendant la campagne de 2019 et
2021 on a proposé un projet loi et les
libraux et les conservateurs ont voté
contre cette projet loi d'avoir des
soins dentaires donc maintenant le fait
que c'est mieux pour les enfants de 10
ans et moi c'est grâce à nos efforts il
y a aucun dû quand vous avez quand vous
avez signé cette entente là avec le
gouvernement Trudeau avec Monsieur
Trudeau on s'était rencontré vous et moi
vous m'aviez dit je vous avais demandé
si vous aviez peur d'être effacé ou
d'être oubliés dans vous m'aviez dit non
vous êtes vous alliez pouvoir tirer
votre épingle du jeu oui est-ce que vous
avez toujours l'impression que vous avez
tirer votre épingle du jeu je pense que
on a toujours le pouvoir de enlever
notre appui donc ça existe toujours et
on a accompli des grandes choses donc je
suis fier de fait que jusqu'à ce moment
à ce qu'on a ce qu'on a dit qu'elle
augmente droit à faire jusqu'au fin de
cette année on a accompli mais on a
aussi ajouté une autre chose le crédit
d'impôt de la TPS doublée on a du blé
donc c'est une autre élément d'or de
l'Entente que on a forcé le goulement de
faire donc les trois grandes enjeux les
trois grandes appuie pour les gens c'est
nous qui l'a fait c'est qui nous l'avons
fait donc jusqu'à ce moment je pense que
on a on a réussi à livrer le marchandise
pour les gens est-ce que c'est difficile
de travailler de concert avec avec le
parti au pouvoir et de le critiquer
aussi en même temps je pense des gens
pensent que c'est difficile mais on a
souvent ces mêmes cette même situation
si je prends l'exemple l'exemple des
travailleurs dans un syndicat oui et
lutte contre l'entreprise et oui ils ont
entendent finalement mais personne dit
que les travailleurs et l'entreprise
sont mêlés comme ça il reste des des
intuitifs séparées donc on est comme
dans un même situation on est forcé le
gourmand de faire des choses on a un
entente mais on peut les critiquer parce
que finalement c'est eux qui sont au
pouvoir c'est le premier ministre qui
décide finalement ce que le pays fait et
on a le pouvoir de les pousser de faire
mieux ou de les critiquer ici il ne le
fait pas j'aimerais vous entendre sur
évidemment dans une perspective
électorale le premier ministre de
l'Ontario dogford a profité de la
dernière campagne pour courtiser
beaucoup beaucoup le milieu des
travailleurs ça a été très payant pour
les conservateurs en Ontario dans le de
la province dans le nord de la province
qui sont des endroits où normalement le
NPD a une base militante très forte on a
l'impression que monsieur poyèvre est en
train de faire un peu la même chose
est-ce que les conservateurs au Canada
sont en train de
gruger votre base de militant je pense
qu'ils essayent de faire ça et je suis
reconnaissant comment ils ont eu des
victoires mais le problème c'est pour
vrai le Parti conservateur et le chef
maintenant ils ont un bilan où ils ont
attaqué les travailleurs et un bilan
récent un des premières choses que
Pierre poly avait fait c'est d'attaquer
les pensions et de attaquer la science
emploi donc une attaque direct au
travailleur donc on peut montrer avec
plusieurs exemples comment ce qu'il
propose va aider les grandes entreprises
il va faire mal au travailleur mais j'ai
visité en Allemagne pour cette raison
parce que ils ont fait une campagne pour
respecter les travailleurs et ils ont eu
la même défi avec des conservateurs qui
essaient de gagner l'appui des
travailleurs donc je suis reconnaissant
que c'est une défi mais je pense que on
a les outils pour combattre ces défis et
de réussir parce que les gens ont besoin
de nous et nous sommes vraiment les
vrais alliés des travailleurs et on va
montrer ça en même temps ils se sont
déjà laissés séduire par les par les
conservateurs en Ontario entre autres
puis on le sent aussi un petit peu sans
doute provinces il y a des mouvements
comment vous faites c'est quoi
l'argument massue pour le chef du NPD de
dire c'est moi qui devrait être là pour
protéger vos intérêts comment vous
faites pour les convaincre on a eu des
exemples comme dogfo un doc food a
commencé en disant que je suis pour les
travailleurs et puis elle a attaqué
l'épreuve avec une une attaque massive
qui écrit une grande révolte des
travailleurs avec une menace une grande
grève une grève toute la province parce
qu'il a directement tac les travailleurs
donc on peut montrer il n'est pas
vraiment votre allié pour les élections
ils a essayé de vous souhaiter dire mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait quand il est au
pouvoir il vous avait attaqué c'est le
même chose que les dernières semaines
fait en Alberta et c'est la même chose
que Pierre polyèvre a déjà fait quand il
était au pouvoir avec Harper c'est la
même chose que Harper donc on a
plusieurs exemple de montrer comment les
conservateurs dit un chose pour gagner
la pluie des travailleurs mais quand ils
sont au pouvoir et fait l'opposé et le
TAC les travailleurs il fait même aller
au travail et c'est nous qui ont fait
les choses pour aider les gens
aujourd'hui les travailleurs au Canada à
10 jours de congé des maladies payées
grâce à nos affaires donc pour les
travailleurs complètement c'est nous qui
les aides est-ce que les Canadiens sont
prêtes à faire face à une récession
comme comme ça risque d'être le cas en
début d'année 2023 non
particulièrement parce que on a une
assurance emploi
ancienne fait par Pierre paulieff quand
elle était au pouvoir comme ministre
continué par Justin Trudeau qui aide
seulement 40% de la population qui
travaille donc 60% de la population
n'ont pas des d'appui si il perdent
leurs emplois donc ça c'est un problème
et deuxièmement avec la coût de la vie
qui augmente avec le coup de les taux
d'intérêt qui augmente et une raciation
ça va vraiment faire mal aux
travailleurs et c'est pourquoi on
continue de milites pour des appuis et
un système qui est prêt pour aider les
travailleurs si on plonge dans un ratio
l'assurance emploi c'est pas si simple
que ça à accomplir en un cours laps de
temps qu'est-ce qu'on fait à court terme
pour s'assurer que les Canadiens sont
prêts à faire face à une récession comme
certains pensent que ça va arriver en
début d'année comme on a fait pendant la
pandémie on a changé rapidement la
science emploi pour le rendre plus
accessible on peut faire la même chose
encore je pense qu'on peut faire ça va
prendre du temps mais on peut faire
aussi des changements de long terme on
peut penser des choses pour cet hiver on
est proposé enlever les TPs sur le
chauffage ça c'est quelque chose de
concret pour aider les familles donc on
va réduire à l'impact sur les
travailleurs parce que sinon ça va être
vraiment terrible l'entente avec les
libéraux allez vous rendre à la fin
ça dépend ça dépend si le gouvernement
fait ce qui ce qu'on a forcé de faire si
brise le promesse s'il y a un grand
scandale il y a plusieurs raisons pour
laquelle on peut enlever notre appui
mais
généralement l'idée que si on peut
continuer d'aider les gens on continue
avec l'Entente si on ne peut pas
continuer de faire ces victoires pour
les gens aider les gens on enlève notre
appui job meeting chef d'une [ __ ] merci
beaucoup je vous en prie